Just how good is Disney's live-action Mulan?
It's no longer as mysterious as the dark side
of the moon the picture is a hit with critics.
Reviewers took to social media to slather
praise all over Mulan after its premiere Monday
evening, their near-unanimous chorus applauding
virtually every aspect of the production.
We know what you're thinking: but what about
the absence of those iconic songs from the
1998 animated original?
How will we contend with the fact that this
Mulan does not feature a tiny, wisecracking
dragon voiced by Eddie Murphy as comic relief?
According to the critics, the answer is simple:
while this Mulan operates in the spirit of
the original, it's also the unique vision
of director Niki Caro, who has apparently
knocked it right the hell out of the park.
"Loyal… brave… and true."
Disney's live-action remakes of their classic
properties have so far been a bit of a mixed
bag, although that bag has contained some
insanely profitable films.
Last year's Dumbo, Aladdin, and The Lion King
were all met with mixed-to-poor reviews, even
as audiences rewarded the latter two with
worldwide grosses well north of $1 billion.
If you caught Mulan's incredibly kick-ass,
full length trailer on Super Bowl Sunday,
though, it shouldn't surprise you to learn
that the professionals were blown away by
the movie.
Star Yifei Liu's steely, charismatic presence,
Caro's assured direction, and the film's stunning
fight choreography were singled out for the
most praise and if you're among those fans
who just can't picture Mulan without the songs,
you may be pleased to know that the live-action
adaptation didn't forget them entirely.
Insider correspondent Kirsten Acuna made it
clear that the filmmakers acknowledged that
the bold choice to exclude the original's
tunes would leave some fans wanting.
She wrote:
"Mulan is absolutely fantastic.
Different enough with great action scenes,
but with the heart of the original film.
It doesn't even matter that it's not a musical.
If you're a fan of the animated [movie], there
are subtle nods to many of the songs.
Can't wait to see this again."
Mashable entertainment editor Angie J. Han
went even further, writing:
"Mulan is the best of the Disney live-action
remakes since Cinderella — I didn't even
miss the songs.
Finds new notes in a story we already know
while delivering gorgeous action, heart, and
humor."
Of course, there were also those critics who
had no particular connection to the original
film; by and large, they, too, enjoyed the
heck out of Mulan.
Slashfilm's Peter Sciretta wrote:
"I'm very surprised at how much I liked the
live action Mulan movie.
It's so majestic, the action is thrilling,
it aims for a level of sophistication and
beauty you don't expect.
(I was never a huge fan of the animated film,
I think I've only seen it once.)"
"You know… we have to work on your people
skills!"
Indeed, Mulan seems to be rather singular
among Disney's live-action remakes in that
it doesn't rely heavily on nostalgia for the
original to carry it.
Instead, it appears to be a film seeking to
carve its own path with its bread and butter
being those killer action sequences.
Kevin Polowy of Yahoo!
Entertainment wrote:
"I've seen Mulan twice now and I must say
it is grrrreat.
Easily Disney's best live action reboot.
I think it's also Disney's first battle epic?
It is beautiful & absorbing & rich & empowering.
The cast is excellent and Niki Caro's direction
is just breathtaking."
That such an expertly-choreographed battle
epic would serve a female empowerment narrative
was also not lost on critics.
The Geekly Show's Tania Lamb wrote:
"Mulan is about a warrior.
And that warrior is a legend.
Thank you, from all the female warriors that
needed this kick-A movie.
It's different from the animated version,
and I'll be proud to show my daughters this
film!"
It's safe to say that offering up a live-action
Mulan so different from its animated predecessor
was a gamble of the sort that Disney's not
exactly known for taking.
Fortunately, in this instance, it appears
to have paid off big time.
We've had a good feeling about this one from
the get-go, and we're pleased that so far,
the critics are proving us right.
"Let me speak, ancestors, of the great warrior
Mulan.
The loyal.
The brave.
The true."
Mulan is scheduled to hit the big screen on
March 27, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.